Speaker 1: Well, my friends, they are putting
the people who incited the January 6th Trump
riots in charge of the investigation
into what happened on January 6th. Yes,
there's going to be a January 6th commission,
but much the same way that Donald Trump wanted
his own lawyers investigating what
happened and telling legislatures
what happened with the election.
Speaker 2: I need 11000 votes.
Give me a break. Exactly.
Speaker 1: They are going
to put in some of the very Republicans whose
denial of the election results and rhetoric
fomented those very riots, which they will now
be investigating. This is like what putting O.J.
Simpson in charge of what happened to Nicole Brown
Simpson. This is like putting, you know, take your
pick. I mean, it's just a wealth of analogies
and metaphors, and none of it makes any sense.
But the goals of Kevin McCarthy, the House
minority leader, in choosing the people that
he chose for this are very, very clear. Esquire
has a nice article by Charlie Pierce about this
called Kevin McCarthy is stacking the January 6th
commission with Big Lie advocates just dumping in
dumps the very people who fomented these riots
to begin with. Let's read this commission,
while certainly better than nothing is doomed to
sink beneath the weight of congressional inertia.
Charlie writes, I am perhaps not
wise in the ways of Washington,
but I fail to see what sense it
makes to allow members of Congress
who have demonstrated their allegiance to the
gross untruth that was at the root of all the
violence onto the special commission tasked
with investigating the January 6th insurrection,
quoting from The Washington Post that
Kevin McCarthy has selected. Listen to this
Congressman Jim Jordan from Ohio and Jim Banks
from Indiana to massive big lie perpetuators,
as well as Rodney Davis, Kelly Armstrong and Troy
Nel's. The lawmakers met with McCarthy on Monday.
Banks said that he has accepted McCarthy's
invitation to serve as the top Republican
on the panel, quote, Because we need leaders who
will force the Democrats and the media to answer
questions so far ignored. I hope you guys know
what that means. Like, I hope you understand
that the point of selecting these people, in
particular banks and especially Jim Jim Jordan,
is they aren't going to be going in with
the perspective of, wow, there was violence,
who caused it and let's hold those people
accountable. That's what it would make sense.
They are going to go in with the perspective of,
wow, there was some violence and it was warranted
because the election was stolen and there was
every reason to believe that Donald Trump may have
been the rightful winner of that election. This is
how backwards this commission is going to be. So
the position we're now in is one of having
to ask. Well, OK, so Republicans, number one,
who are are investigating, quote, investigating
are perpetuators. They should be witnesses rather
than investigators. But number two, they're not
really even going to investigate. They're going to
try to perpetuate the big lie as a justification
for what took place. These people were angry
and some committed crimes and the court system
will deal with that. But these people were rightly
angry because it does appear as though there was
funny business here and there was funny business
there. And we had all the reasons to believe that
the election may not have been done the way it
should have been done. That's what they're
going to do. So then the question is, well,
is it worth is it a net gain to do it at all,
given that Democrats will have their opportunity
to show the the violence and all of the other
stuff? I actually question it. I actually question
it because the people who are going to fall for
the Republican approach to this committee, to this
commission aren't even going to listen to what the
Democrats have to say. And I really question what
is going to productively come out of this. I'm not
sure if it's a net gain, quite frankly. Let's look
look at a little bit more here. Among the five
white men selected by McCarthy, three of them
voted against certifying the current president's
victory. All of them voted against impeaching
Trump for his role in inciting the violence that
descended upon the capital. To be entirely fair,
Nel's, a former sheriff, apparently was of
invaluable assistance to the Capitol Police
when when Congress was under siege. Of course,
Tiger beat on the Potomac has found the proper
euphemisms while the California Republican took
his time deciding between naming more experienced
members to the probe, filling his seats with
firebrand's and refusing to tap any members
at all. McCarthy. McCarthy ultimately chose to
go with the former route with his selections.
His his picks have the committee leadership
and oversight chops to counter Democrats who
are expected to use the select panel to hammer
Trump and the Republican Party for fueling the
deadly assault on the Capitol in which Jim Jordan
is no longer a firebrand. If he takes this is an
attack on his previous four years of service, he
might burn the Capitol down. So this is going to
be an absolute gong show. We may cover some or
much of it or maybe none of it live. I'm not
sure exactly what we're going to do yet. But if
you're expecting that aha moment, maybe a come to
Jesus moment, for lack of a better term, we're
Republicans. The vast majority will say, wow,
Trump really had a lot to do with
what happened on January 6th.
No, that's absolutely not going to happen. And
what will come of this remains a real question